[Music]
should dozens of camels get dumped for
enhancing their humps
yeah camels were banned for the rest of
their lives for getting more surgery
than the real housewives
43 campbells not to be confused with
what cat smokes during lunch
have been disqualified from a popular
beauty contest in saudi arabia for using
botox fillers and other cosmetic
enhancements not to mention the breast
implants
some were even accused of inflating body
parts using rubber bands to make them
look better
so that's how it works
anyway roll past that joke
and that joke anyway it's a big loss for
the disqualified but they're still
eligible for next year's swimsuit issue
now breeders compete for more than 66
million dollars in prize money and if
they win they can sell the camel for a
higher price
but it raises a question is it wrong for
camels to use the very same tools that
humans do to enhance their beauty
whether it's botox or fillers
we go to someone who understands this
more than anyone
what do you think yeah i got a face full
of surgery
[Laughter]
i think i'd be more voluptuous looking
if that was the case
but what's up oh i don't know i didn't i
didn't get this i didn't i didn't know
that a camel could be hot you know yeah
yeah oh you haven't lived i've never
looked at a group of camels i've been
like oh no no that one
has it yes yes so i don't get it you
know pretty soon uh carly we're gonna
have trans camels oh
transgender in the competition well we
all know that hollywood is a horrible
place and i guess those
this is such a ridiculous story those
unneces those
unattainable beauty standards are also
affecting the animal kingdom now how
dare they that is such a good point
sonny are we are the unrealistic beauty
standards that we uh we demand on
ourselves spreading to the drama dairies
nice thank you
66 million dollars yes like okay i i
want to breed some camels let's see what
we can let's see what we can do here but
you got to see this is the funny part
everything everything that happens over
there comes over here so if you start
thinking about the fact of the tax
credits they put out for the llamas and
how all the people in like california
and the hills started to buy llamas for
the tax credits watch they're going to
have a llama beauty contest very very
soon coming out of hollywood i didn't
know there was a tax credit for llamas
if you if you're any of them if you
raise and breed llamas on your property
especially in california there's a tax
credit for it that's why people have
started to buy who wants a llama
nobody wants a llama why are they
running around with llamas because it
gives you
[Music]
and now you're going to have a beauty
contest yes will what do you think
um i think this shows anytime there's a
competition you will find cheaters right
and cat not only is it fun to think
somebody said now that camel has it but
there's another guy that said if you
pumped up her lips
somebody said that candle's close but if
you made a few tweaks
i don't know the difference between a
hot camel and a camel who is not sexy
and i think that's a good thing i can do
that with the lights off
and i have
i think the dollar amount beside the
camel's worth is what differentiates the
two that's all i can come up with you
know what that was a perfect friday
segment hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else